dans ce cas là c'est un peu la trouille
on découvre est un personnage finalement
plus complexe que tu en as l'air le
dimanche après midi avec une vision un
peu comme des poupées russes qui qui
s'emboîtent
il fallait des poupées soviétique est le
premier personnage celui que tout le
monde connait c'est le jacques martin
ils ont un peu comme ça peu démago faut
bien dire un peu gras populaire nantes
je sais pas je t'ai vu dimanche dernier
à la télévision quand tu disais dans mon
émission c'est le monde est à vous il
n'y a pas de gagnant il n'y a pas
d'événement c'est les gens utilisant la
gagner et ce bourg passer toute façon on
est tous dans le même bateau depuis
vercingétorix
c'est un peu non pas du tout je le pense
on est on est quand même pas tous dans
le même bateau et sont demandés dans des
bars casse et d'autres qui seront
demandés y hautement bruit parce que les
gens parce que la nature fait que les
choses sont inégales au départ mais je
pense que quand on a la chance d'avoir
un bon bateau il faut aider les petites
barques as je crois que s'il existe un
cheval rire de ce que j'appelle entre
guillemets les intellectuels mais jean
de ça cette maison prêts d'honneur à ne
jamais se servir de ce que l'on sait aux
dépens de gens qui ne savent pas alors
le dimanche je ne fais pas de démagogie
j'aime ces gens ces gens font partie
intégrante de ma vie et je faisais cette
réflexion faut pas la négliger ce grand
texte à propos de chansons ne change
jamais entendu qui m'inquiétait on a
gagné on a gagné
et ça veut dire qu'on a perdu
[Musique]
quand tu vas à la concorde étudient dans
france soir que j'ai pris le risque de
situation soit soit menacée du cdja
qu'avec l'audimat ce que tu fais sur la
deûle dimanche après midi sa situation
n'est pas un assez grand j'en ai vu
d'autres
daniel ziegler danièle gilbert faisait
face à une très belle émission vous avez
laissé ces mots bibi surnom adi
elle faisait 28 noms que j'ai quand même
une certaine habileté de la télé ça fait
35 ans français et c'est pas moi qui
suis inquiet parce que moi
personnellement ça ne m'inquiète pas
trop tu vois mais ce sont mes camarades
autour de moi puis ont voté tu penses
que tu as pris un risque en allant la
concorde
oui un certain si on est vraiment un
professionnel en travaillant sur
l'oiseau l'état où les gens savent bien
qu'en prenant position quand on le
pouvoir
généralement ça se paye mais je dis pas
je te dis pas que le on va me virer nous
attaquons aujourd'hui les gens mais il
je suis en tête de me chercher ta ville
candidate qui a fait zéro oui alors il
ya là un candidat qui a fait zéro alors
tu dis on bat toute façon moi aussi tu
ranges talent éclate je vais toujours
zéro risque
et puis c'est pas grave d'avoir zéro
alors on sait jamais si tu as eu le
certificat d'études seulement le
baccalauréat s'arrêter ou tes études ça
officiellement ça c'est ah oui j'ai eu
le certificat d du nul pour ovins et
puis c'est bien bien bien bien plus tard
j'ai commencé mes études j'ai recommencé
mes études mais est-ce que ça c'est pas
tout ça de la provocation un peu contre
les intellos et la gauche caviar que tu
détestes jeunes et aux familles de gast
et si à l'occasion d'un d'un nouveau mai
68 qui avait quelque chose je dirais
placer quelques grenades népal
observateurs j'ai ouï sont mes ennemis
de passe
ça fait 30 ans que ces gens là si sur ce
que je fais me sur mes livres sur les
films sur les émissions de télé alors
pendant une trentaine d'années j'en ai
eu peur ni moi donc
il je vous remercie de m'avoir dit dans
le journal de terrain en soirée
ouais voilà même jour disait bonjour le
soir quand je les rencontre là chez
castel que la gauche va chez castel et
puis un certain mois on évolue tu vois
j'ai attrapé mes 55 ans et pas mal
d'autres choses aussi et je me suis dit
que j'étais complètement con de pactiser
avec les ennemis donc maintenant tu la
rendre payante à doha il faut savoir que
maintenant je vais tirer leur tiennent
les tirs aient eu parce que la gauche
que je déteste c'est pas bien entendu
les communismes où les gens qui sont
vraiment du peuple celle efossa gloin
les petits [ __ ] j'avoue j'ai lu dans
le canard enchaîné disent que lyon et
maintenant qu'est louis je suis à
comique pour n'ose évoquer une chose
l'alphabet est que je suis représentant
de commerce comme si dire de quelqu'un
c'était en présence dans le commerce
était une injure c'est ça un racisme tu
étais un représentant de commerce de
rodez but en 12 jeux tout fait moi ouais
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
quelque part c'est fini je ne fais plus
de concessions des ennemis faut qu'il le
sache je suis dit pour quelqu'un qui est
pas franc maçon et qu'il fait pas partie
du récit je me suis pas mal des maires
des seuils le satin oui oui ma revanche
qua non j'ai pas de revanche et plus
dimanche à prendre ton nom rebonds je
vais maquette n'est pas ici quand on a
55 ans mathématiquement on a moins de
temps moins de temps à passer sur cette
terre on en a déjà
oui de la session a fait le plus gros
bon on a fait le plus gros seins sur le
thème les 55 par deux ça ferait 110
on n'y arrive pas c'est sedan qui me
reste moins de temps a passé et comme je
suis un sybarites que j'aime le bonheur
que j'aime vivre que j'aime la vie
passionnément je ne vais plus m'emmerder
est beaucoup plus jeune que les autres
je suis arrivé un état raisonnable je
les histoires de la terre ne me concerne
pas tellement parce que le mieux même si
je commets commettait un meurt
aujourd'hui le minimum dont je courais
copé serait inférieur au temps qui me
reste est donc je n'en ai rien à [ __ ]
qui tu déteste le plus
mais personne personne je trouve pénible
certaines attitudes par exemple je
trouve très très pénibles l'attitude de
guy bedos la semaine dernière et si
j'étais françois mitterrand je
convoquerai billy budd au centre en lui
disant arrêtez vous fait du tort à sa
table des lois oui parce que tu vois
dans l'émission de ce charmant copains
il a été faire d'être comment notre
charmant comme dechavanne dechavanne qui
démarre son émission qui est là tout
timide parce qu'on est timide les 15
premières années ont fait de la
télévision
s'il sait il faut quinze ans pour céder
minimise et voilà que guy fait du
terrorisme et lui dit une chose méchante
qui m'a frappé si vous continuez cette
émission je verrai vous faites là en
france mais que c'est agréable quand on
sait le doute qui habite dechavanne ce
garçon timide tellement timide qui parle
vite par tort d'avoir un trou et est un
charmant garçon lui a dit je fais la
première et sans doute dernier dont tu
vois est ce que tu crois que de la part
d'un mec qui à bientôt 60 ans et la
burqa est une île à 60 ans mais plus ça
vous vous de 70 alors est ce que tu
crois que c'est bien qu'avec de 60 ans
riche parce que c'est cher les sept
événements viennent faire des
terroristes intellectuels auprès de
chavannes qui commence alors que de
chavanette à charmant garçon est ce que
c'est bien de la part de guy l'osdh ôter
le pain du match que igor qui est un ami
et qui fait qui inventaient les parfums
pour attirer non est ce qu'on a le droit
quand on a une place de tir et ils sont
gagne par les autres seront pas disons
que je trouve cette attitude négative
mais je ne déteste pas veut nous c'est
pas de sa faute c'est un enfant
valeureux prolongée taylor il ya un
autre martin c'est le martin écorché
c'est de martin qui a souffert quand il
était petit oui là j'ai souffert mais
tout le monde a souffert j'ai souffert
jusqu'à jeu j'ai souffert j'ai souffert
mais tout le monde c'est vrai que ton
père est revenue de la guerre de 14 e
coli qu'à cause de ce qu'ils avaient vu
pendant la guerre bree mon père a fait
la guerre de 14 18 il avait 20 verges en
14 et
il était officier il a été officier au
front évidemment il a vu pourtant voir
ce qu'il faisait et il est resté y les
bords de ça pendant la nuit dans un
collège personne ne me convenait pas
doivent avoir travaillé enfin c'est
toute une histoire ça c'est très un type
saas permet d'en parler complètement
j'ai refusé 20 fois de raconter mairie
par contre je veux bien raconter mon
voyage ce que je veux bien raconté c'est
l'histoire d'un garçon qui est parti à
15 ans chez lui même bien avant est
parti à 6 ans chez lui et a rencontré
tout ce que j'ai rencontrés car j'ai
rencontré des gens extraordinaires comme
un truc fou c'est face on le sait même
s'il a jamais raconté ces cas un jour tu
as fait une fugue et personne personne
n'a cherché
oui aussi mais ça n'est pas très
important mais ce que j'ai ramené de ce
que j'ai vu c'est une enviable
j'ai quand même connu mal à park j'ai
connu jouant dont je connaissais je n'ai
j'ai connu des tas de gens des tas de
choses j'ai fait le tour du monde
plusieurs fois parce que je suis curieux
tout ça c'est intéressant raconte et
c'est ce que je vais raconter enfin
liste la comédie musicale que je qu'on
va donner à au théâtre marigny à partir
du 22 septembre
ça s'appelle la lune avec les dents et
c'est l'histoire d'un mec qui s'appelle
martin dupont ou durand qui est né en
1933 et il monte il sait ça y est c'est
ce que j'ai croisé la route c'est ça et
c'est drôle mais est ce que t'as pas été
embringué finalement dans la télé comme
ça parce que fit talent et c'était les
six enfants à nourrir coelho non pas du
tout j'ai tort brogi parle at-il dans la
telus parce que j'avais eu un chagrin
d'amour avec le cinéma
ouais oui comme mon film est sorti on
avait tourné à nice
je crois qu'il y avait beaucoup de
choses
dedans beaucoup de choses formidables et
bien avant la lettre
et puis les intellectuels de gauche ont
tiré dans le dos par taye vont me dire
être dans à bout portant et il a bien
fallu payer le film représentera la télé
mais quand tu as quitté midi magazine la
première fois tu as dit par goût de la
sécurité ou par lâcheté je pourrais
rester là oui et puis finalement si je
restais là j'y serais encore dans 30 ans
oui bien sûr est ce que finalement ce
pas ce qui était arrivé je suis pas
lassé 30 ans ça fait dix ans que je suis
rentré en plus qu'est-ce que je devais
ouais parce que je suis très loin de la
maison mère ouais j'ai un théâtre 41-10
pas grave j'ai la même équipe petite
équipe courte nuit je fais de la télé et
on est très très très très très très
très très loin des discussions de
couloir ou du côté et comme la maison
antennes de la confiance en moi je suis
un petit peu gouverneur général jean
louis jean voit de temps en temps
quelqu'un cherchait des drum n'est ou
des enveloppes à la maison mère à la
maison mère mais en dehors de ça le
théâtre de leur pire on fait tout
nous-mêmes et les livres ne regrette pas
de l'avoir écrit parce que tu as fait un
mort disent rien ils sont en train de
préparer plusieurs livres ça que
maintenant finalement au bout de
quelques années et a fini par admettre
comme take what a pu ces velléités que
tout le monde a c'est à dire de fanon
j'ai évolué et penser qu'ils pourraient
être reçus presser au sol supérieure
puis à des tas de préoccupations qu'ils
tombent aux bulls au bout de six enfants
entre eux pensent à mieux comprendre la
famille
au bout de deux mariages ont saisi violé
femmes plus est au bout de 25 ans de
spectacle on est revenus de pas mal de
vanité sur le show business ont la
fragilité nos professions
et puis moi la seule chose qui
m'intéresse c'est de bien vivre la
minute qui m'est donnée comme à présent
de bien vivre celle d'après de bien
vivant demain et dans reste je m'en fous
ça n'a aucune espèce d'importance
puisque je considère que nous sommes de
passage c'est la psychanalyse qui t'a
aidé beaucoup mais c'est très loin de
psychanalyse on dans sa case
c'est pour débarrasser du catholicisme
que la finale se tiendra du tout où je
suis je suis un croyant extraordinaire
je crois la résurrection
je crois fortement est-ce que tu choisis
frei dès mon dieu mais en réalité il ya
un dieu il ya un dieu mais on l'appelle
dicks pour arranger tout le monde
on va pas faire de racisme justement
c'est ça mais je crois à la résurrection
tu vois il ya un écrivain américain qui
s'appelle richard bach ou qui a écrit
une phrase définitive sur lequel tous
les êtres humains devraient méditer
il faut bien écouter ça ce que la
chenille appelle la fin du monde
lemaitre lui l'appelle le papillon et je
pense exactement ce à quoi nous nous
sommes des chenilles et quelque part si
on se place sur un autre degré moi je
sais qu'on ressuscite en papillon et
j'en ai même la preuve
vous allez les amis alors j'ai 30 ans de
télévision mais c'est la première fois
que je vois un plateau de cette qualité
comment allez-vous vieux bull road rage
sur votre âge et quand même année ils
demandent si tu as pas une place dans
ton émission pour le vestiaire tout ce
que mange absolument guira en ce moment
est un peu
et alors la magie je sais pas par quels
instituts et les passes et mairie fait
ouais bon alors comment tu vas toi aussi
bien que toi
ouais on est sur une chaîne béni nous
sommes nous avons la chance d'avoir des
directeurs merveilleux je dis ça parce
que j'aime les croisières police serait
ça va tu vois non savent pas combien je
suis je suis complètement ébouriffés
partant des corps mais complètement
ébouriffés sauf que c'est génial
alors moi je t'ai connu dans une
émission très très difficile très hard
et ready stroy qui s'appelait un égal 3
c'est écouter et la première émission
comique que j'ai fait avec jean yanne on
en a fait 3 et 1 la quatrième en nous a
virés
ah oui c'était comme ça à l'époque ça
n'a pas changé mais c'est devenu plus
coup j'étais qu'il pdg à l'époque je
suis plus tu sais les pdg ça change
alors après il ya eu quand même la
lorgnette et une petit rapporteur il ya
eu les dimanches
s'il ya eu les dimanches oui mais je
trouve un peu plus respectable quand
même qu'avant tu étais un peu rangé des
voitures et tu as dit d'ailleurs la fin
de l'assaut lancé le commencement de la
vieillesse est-ce que tu atteins j'avais
dit il sans actualiser absolument ans
entre guillemets est-ce que tu n'as pas
l'impression d'être devenu un peu trop
respectable écoute tu regarde pas mes
émissions jusqu'au bout parce qu'avec la
nouvelle émission un petit sa peine à
s'y font font font déjà eu pas mal de
lettres recommandées
ce qui prouve que on a retrouvé le temps
mais je vais pas te reprocher de faire
une émission qui marche parce qu'on rêve
tous de faire des émissions qui marchent
aussi bien que la tienne mais est ce que
finalement après quinze ans de dimanche
martin qui va pas un peu comme au boulot
ah non je vois ma part parce qu'on a une
excellente équipe ouais on vit dans un
merveilleux théâtre et tu sais par
expérience que aucune émission ne
ressemble à une autre
il ya toujours l'inattendu il ya les
jours avec et des jours sans
je pense que faire de la télévision est
un métier extraordinaire
d'ailleurs beaucoup de gens jeunes
rêvent d'en faire j'espère qu'ils n'en
font pas trop tôt pour jouer reste
encore un joli des fois par exemple je
me regarde faire certes et tu te bats
faisant ton émission encore bien sûr on
se regarde faire c'est tout à fait
normal mais la chose que je n'ai jamais
fait c'est de me regarder la télévision
je ne peux pas supporter a largement
ceux qui m'aiment beaucoup d'acquis
commence pas alors tel client idéal pour
double jeu parce qu'en fait il ya le
jacques martin qu'on voit tous les
dimanches après-midi qu'on aime quand le
tas de gens regardent
effectivement il ya l'autre suit qui est
passionné par la musique par la
littérature
alors tu fais quoi pour la musique parce
que moi j'ai entendu dire je suis pas en
province là où j'ai ma maison géante
redire s'était vue dimanche après midi
je suis argentin je suis venu donner un
concert spirituel dans la cathédrale
pour la société de musique d'argentan on
a fait un concert prokofiev vrai
on a joué une pièce de mozart qui n'est
pas trop connue en fin d'année un
concert et ça a permis à la société
musicale d'argent attendront prendre
pied à dire que tu termines
l'enregistrement de dimanche par talent
le samedi soir et le chauffard aurait
salle de concert le dimanche
et j'adore ça je dois être cru non pas
du tout non mais je m'éclate
il ya un autre jacques martin c'est lui
qui lit parce qu'on dit toujours que tu
peut réciter
on dit toujours ça fait partie de la
légende que tu peut réciter des pages
entières de mark twain de ce oui le pin
touch la lecture est une mauvaise
habitude qu'il faut prendre très jeune
ouais je pense que mon enfance ayant été
une enfance très très malheureuse est
très solitaire je me suis réfugié dans
la dans les livres et je lis depuis
depuis l'âge de raison je crois que je
lui je vis dans l'élite depuis l'âge de
huit ans et c'est une mauvaise habitude
que j'ai conservée jusqu'au jour mais
cette gêne pas que les gens le
connaissent que celui que que tu
appelles la bonne à tout faire du
dimanche après-midi le teil de ton
émission le nastic à tout le monde joue
un double jeu
ce qui n'a qu'une personne à gratter
grilles anti pour nous venger disons que
j'ai plusieurs double jeu mais tous les
êtres humains sont douze il ya
l'apparence et à l'être intérieur il ya
dix ans le moal sur moi pour faire
potentiel et c'est vrai qu'on dit
souvent êtes cultiver pour un animateur
oui voilà vous est propre pour un
sénégalais c'est exactement la même
chose
on me dit il est vrai il y avait la niva
terrain c'est pas c'est pas ensuite pas
dérangeant comme disait courteline c'est
une volupté d'être pris pour un imbécile
par ses contemporains
c'était pas empêché quand même d'écrire
et blanc passe moi l'épongé qui va me
une chanson qui va payer ma première
voiture à et oui une connerie ça paie
une voiture tandis qu'une chanson
intelligente ça paye même pas c'est
comment et blanc passe mal étrange c'est
un chef-d'oeuvre de la poésie française
va nous le faire oui je peux te dire le
port est l'autre samedi ma femme
germaine me dit tu vas prendre un bain
ça fait bien plus de huit semaines que
tu ne t'es pas laver les mains c'est
beau quand même près et laure france et
vlan pasmal éponge et vlan fais-moi
gligli et vlan passe moi l'épongé
et vlan et c'est là la trouvaille
bouzigues aussi qu'il faut jouer les
rambo
[Applaudissements]
cadets
presque pas tout ça quand même de passer
2 et blanc passe moi l'épongé a pint
heures de painter a mis enfin voilà qu
est de tout ça à l' empire
t'es pas dans la vie doit être qu est ce
que tu es quelqu'un de stressé au fond
je l'étais mais je le suis alors jacques
tu as eu une enfance est là à la dickens
un peu un peu ton père avait fait la
guerre de 14 il était parti à 20 ans
carrière vincent qui est de faire la
grande guerre oui il en était devenu
complètement excentré et
du vin pourquoi pas un peu c'est un
euphémisme il buvait tout le temps du
whisky non si lui tomber dessus
ouais une fois il paraît qu'il a vu de
l'autre colonne ça doit être pour ça que
j'ai les cheveux bouclés
il en est mort oui il en est mort mais
il a pris son temps c'est un homme à toi
tu te retrouves au collège auquel est ce
lui convenait pas voir très souvent pas
trop non mais gt gt dans un collège dans
un collège catholique
j'ai reçu une éducation très dures qu'il
m'a fait trouvé après la vie
merveilleuse carrière j'ai bien joué
après s'en être en vacances après mes
allées de conditions c'était mal vu
parce que ta mère payés en retard
oui un petit peu mais qui n'ont tu sais
tout je sais tout très dense et 1
c'était une enfance assez morose
je dirais pas avoir dû chauffer la colle
et voilà mais il a lu ma vie le plus
jeune n'a pas encore écrit en novembre
directe par les foyers entre les mains
oui c'est assez banal tout ça mais c'est
ce qui conduit ou théâtre et là j'ai
vraiment trouvé une famille et depuis je
n'ai jamais trahi ce qu'ont ils à faire
le pitre collège voilà pour finir pitre
à la télévision finalement tu trouves
cette éducation pas mauvaise tué parce
que tu dis est ce qu'il dit aujourd'hui
qu'il faut avoir une éducation à ces
directives pour ses enfants
je pense que c'est très important que
l'éducation soit unie puni prg dont on
triomphe aujourd'hui à six enfants
6 mais j'ai enfin fini n'a pas fini tu
dis que georges qui trouve tout super
génial et un peu déçu de tout laxisme
aux barons se manger mieux que mes
enfants me trouve sympa que dallas mais
c'était pas un service à là on est trop
sympa avec eux je pense qu'être père
c'est être père
jusqu'au mois mes enfants peuvent
compter sur moi jusque dans les pires
moments
je suis leur père dont je suis deux
partis pris c'est eux que j'ai d'abord
je suis là chemin de parti pris pour mes
enfants uniques la première erreur c'est
pas avoir jeté la bouteille de ketchup
le premier jour tout ça aussi avant
j'étais vexé parce que j'aime la cuisine
c'est dans la famille c'est l'unique
grand père était cuisinier du dard et
mon grand père était chef de cuisine du
dialogue est aussi souhaité être touchés
maintenant que le dollar risque de
revenir grâce à vous tu risques tu
risques de toucher peut-être l'enfant
russe tu sais qui risque de le
rembourser je sais toutes les familles
françaises en ont plein dans leur
armoire est où le plat l'an dernier non
je ne pense pas pour touche l'emprunt
russe sais quoi mais pour revenir aux
enfants je pense qu'il ya un seul truc
est important quand on est des enfants
c'est l'exemplarité
quand tu les vois regard des dessins
animés japonais ou ou manger du ketchup
et arabes s'est passé oui mais justement
celui du texte avaient mis des petits
mots dans les livres rares oui ces
visites de vendée pas cette édition pour
acheter un vélo seul vrai à l'époque
et puis finalement ils ont pas touché
non je les en remercie est ce qu'ils
montrent des enfants
bien sûr ça tombe bien les enfants aussi
bien que moi un mois il a montré très
bien oui tu vas voir cela
[Applaudissements]
nous non
j'ai fait l'école des fans ouais je sais
comme des femmes décollage
j'avais à l'époque j'avais 5 ans tu t'es
n'habitait site et dave ça s'est passé à
l'émission elle-même ça s'est bien passé
mais bon pour passer à l'émission
jacques martin était un peu spéciale qu
avec les enfants leur demander des trucs
un peu bizarres
vous avez montré des choses bizarres à
bout à l'époque ouais ouais par exemple
bajaur des attouchements des choses
comme ça quoi
carrément [ __ ] de temps à parler ce
genre de choses c'est tellement
traumatisante que quelque part et il est
en face de vous aujourd'hui vous lui
diriez quoi ça laisse de gros
dégueulasse et je lui mettrais une
énorme gifle et je dirais qu'il ya
beaucoup vous l'air c'est ma vie en fait
campagne de diffamation contre jacques
martin on a besoin de témoignages vous
dites que vous allez participer à
l'école des fans et vous aviez cinq ans
et d'essayer ou via les îles essayer de
vous violez ok oui attention va tourner
loiselle vous avez fait l'école des
femmes janvier quel âge où j'avais 5 ans
et je chantais très bien à l'époque
s'est très mal passé je crois savoir
effectivement très mal passé jacques
martin m'a violée je soutiens que mam
elle dit ouvert la brèche je puis
m'exprimer ainsi car depuis ou êtes fait
tiré par foucault et sabatier sébastien
s'est bâtit aussi le japon l'inde ou la
chine ou je te remercie pour tout ce que
tu as fait pour moi est bon mais ça va
quoi je veux sur humide quand même de
mes émotions je ne vous a jamais aux
maisons voici de nombreuses victimes des
enfants qui sort du casting de de
jacques martin et qui se sont tous fait
plus ou moins violés ils ont tous été
victimes d'attouchements des images
terribles
hélas
[Applaudissements]
disons à une approche large et les
filles alors là c'est fini là je peux
plus faire une école des fans les maires
vont ramasser leurs proches denis turan
et satin radi a refusé de témoigner mais
en a gros sur la patate a pour sa part
dit pas mais ça s'est passé beaucoup
plus tard ait accueil star debbie savoy
si vous me voulez mon fonds de commerce
la dent mais tout le monde connaît ma
fille rassure toi tu lis dans dix mois
je dormais dans les courriers alors aidé
à me téléphoner pour savoir pourquoi tu
touchais pas les vedettes dix mois cette
enfance au fond quand même elle t'a
laissé un petit complexe parce que
certaines espèces d'amertume quand même
non je ne suis pas du tout amer je fume
très mécontents ouais mais content de
moi
ouais enfin la libération le nouvel obs
et quand même maintenant je me tue alors
jeudi à libération je lis tous les
matins elle en a très bien fait et puis
je vis à l'autre bord pour me faire une
opinion non non j'étais un peu
réconcilié avec tous ces gens-là qua non
juste comment avec le temps on à la
juste mesure des choses et tu l'as dit
bonsoir quand tu les vois chez castel ne
soit rien c'est l'aliment bien sûr je
les vois tous les sans fin moi quand je
suis prêt je les connais depuis dix ans
un moment tu leur en voulez plus quand
ben oui parce qu'à un moment de sa
carrière on est d'une susceptibilité
vis-à-vis de la personne à tous les gens
qui vous attaquent on voudrait les voir
voué aux gémonies clouée sur des poteaux
de douleur puis en réalité avec quand
même la sagesse qui vous vient qu'on
s'aperçoit que tout ça c'est une vaste
farce et que ce n'est pas très important
et qu'il faut reconnaître quand on fait
un métier public que les gens vous tombe
dessus
tu te rends compte que c'est juste la
semaine il ya des articles comme ça
qu'ils ont fait ça c'est pas de ma faute
c'est que des témoignages spontanés
pouvait avoir cédé témoignages spontanés
je vais couper les moyens vont commencer
viens je vais te donner un cachot
caché à kiev lviv en attendant si
j'essaie d'arrêter en dix mois
non quand même là bon c'est vrai que
halte à une certaine sérénité au mieux
un pinceau et à se seraient ils avaient
diablerets l'armée par exemple quand à
fena ils ont toujours plus éreinté
fermenté film que tes émissions
quant à l'alena et un jour une seule
critique et cesser demain on fait du mal
quand même
oui ça fait beaucoup de ça fait ça fait
beaucoup de peine mais c'est pas très
important
et puis dans notre métier il faut avoir
la peau comme du cuir
ouais sinon il vaut mieux pas le faire
parce qu'on est appuyé à souffrir toute
sa vie c'est vrai que n'importe qui dans
cette profession a le droit de dire lui
cet art à garons lui s'éteint c'est ta
misérable c'est cse ça fait partie
implicitement du contrat même dans la
rue des fois d'automobilistes s'arrête
jamais rien fait je fais ma gymnastique
ce matin et le mec il a baissé la glace
il m'a dit sale con il appartient
il était une fois contre connaît
[Applaudissements]
contre le choléra qui remédie dont il a
un témoin qui les faux jules a eu avant
moi
1 ouais bon c'est un mec remarquable
quand il se connaît rachdi le mettre
dehors
alors je sais pourquoi je le sénat c'est
un pde faut jeter ce micra après les
miens je veux pas le dire parce que je
vais pas balancer sur un copain dix mois
la première fois que j'étais interviewé
c'était dans une émission qui s'appelait
bain de minuit sur la sur la cgt plus
amer envers l'intelligentzia et il y
avait quelque chose dont tu parlais pas
trop à l'époque parce que ça venait
d'arriver cet état prises de position en
88 à la concorde pour chirac et tu
disais oui c'est une erreur je veux pas
en parler
les jeux j'ai vraiment je les fais par
amitié ouais bah ça ne concerne pas de
jacques chirac
ouais c'est une histoire que sur lequel
je vais avoir où je veux pas qu'on en
parle alors dis moi tu as un fou de
bouaye âge comme un fou hein j'adore ça
coûte un maximum d'argent ces voyages
ont eu oui c'est bon celui qui m'avait
ou n'importe où il ya des gens je suis
curieux de de ce qu'il ya sur la terre
c'est trop bête quand même de quitter ce
cette boule ronde sans avoir eu la
politesse en faire le tour c'est vrai
que des fois quand fait pas le temps de
partir en voyage tu vas déjeuner à
l'aéroport c'est vrai ça c'est quand
j'étais jeune ouais et tu as dit que le
meilleur moment en fait la moitié du
plaisir c'était le taxi entre paris et
voilà le meilleur moment du voyage c'est
quand on prend un taxi et qu'on va vers
l'aéroport parce que ça n'est pas encore
commencé mais une fois dans l'avion
c'est déjà du passé simple
après sa fugue donc du collège là était
arrivé à paris alors tu as fais plein de
boulot comme tous les gens qui
débarquent à pareille ça c'est toujours
le côté du quai c'est toujours le côté
dickens qui continuent alors bon tu as
été secrétaire a été chauffeur de m mais
tu as été aussi livreur pour une société
de dessous féminins raconte de la cité
très très troublant je ne connaissais
rien des choses et encore moins des
dessous féminins et je me travaillait à
travers paris pour aller livrer des
slips qui s'appelait volupté ouais bon
soir soir c'est pourquoi je me suis donc
baladé pendant un an à travers pariant
avec des combinaisons des slips des
soutiens gorge et par deux constantes et
des figurants donc le soir à la comédie
fera la comédie française
on s'amuse avec double jeu fric le jeu
et c'est vrai quand je vais choisir un
pseudo qui était femme non ça s'est
passé ainsi si vous le dire comme
fabrice deniel
c'est quoi j'avais 12 ans je rêvais de
faire du théâtre jean cahiers de classe
je faisais des fausses affiches je
m'étais trouvé un nom de terreur qui
était plus petit alors que j'avais 13
ans je laime appelé fabrics de claire
regard oui ce serait difficile à porter
aujourd'hui j'imagine même pas prise
dimanche par brice de claire regard de
dieu
j'ai commencé à marcher c'est le début
de la gloire éviter pas mal d'échecs en
faut bien le dire aussi
comme tout le film n'a c'était quoi
parce qu'on parle toujours de na c'était
à rome hold up à deux à l'heure et ça
n'est pas évident de faire rire avec un
sujet sur les gens âgés parce que les
gens ont peur des gens âgées ça
terrorise un peu les gens et puis je
suis pas c'était peut-être un peu naïve
dans la facture et je crois que ça n'a
pas été un succès loin de là ça m'a
coûté image est due à rentrer à la télé
pour payer et ça t'a coûté aussi pas mal
d'années dans les supermarchés à faire
des signatures non c'était avant c'est
pour pouvoir faire le film j'ai fait des
signatures dans les supermarchés comme
on en fait tous rennes si tu n'en fais
pas un jour à perdre alors j'aime bien
ta mort assez enrichissant
il annule entre les dents qu'est ce qui
s'est passé c'est la même question
ouais je veux pas en parler non plus je
ne fais pas du mal comme ça en se fixant
les objectifs très très difficile de
vouloir faire plein de choses en même
temps et je crois que c'est le secret de
la virile du mal
non pas du tout il faut se fixer des
objectifs très haut très haut
et puis si on loupe attend pur commence
il ya pas de honte on a cassé la gueule
alors finalement tu aurais pu être curé
archevêque archevêques auraient pu être
chanteur d'opéra tu aurais pu être
journaliste aurait pu être écrivain
animateur télé précédemment l'impression
d'avoir gâché un immense talent alors là
je viens on expliqué et ce sera en tête
à tête si tu veux bien un le concernant
harry maintenant mais le prends pas mal
ça suffit
[Applaudissements]
game one
jacques est en train de me suis arrêté
pour la ducasse comme ça tu me fout en
l'air mon émission et tour était
l'invité c'est des questions c'est
vraiment c'est c'est terrible et si tu
me connais tu sèmes exposé me souviens
en copains et puis d'un seul coup c'est
c'est un piège
en vérité jamais vu mes émissions non
mais bon les autres oui émoussé ces
différences quand même je sais pas on
est sur la même chaîne
sur la même chaîne le notable sur les
autres mais enfin la chine vers la voile
et quoique estime que je m'excuse
ok moi je m'excuse voix l'argentine ont
bloqué je te prie de m'excuser non pas
comme ça ça s'est joué
je veux je te prie non simplement comme
tu le ferais un soir où tu rentré très
tard et où je dis à ta femme j'ai été
retenu dans la télévision s'était retenu
par la télévision
excuse moi avoue quand même que t'es pas
facile à vivre
c'est normal sinon je devrais faire
notre métier c'est pour ça que tu as été
mariée trois fois non non non c'est pas
qu'aux j'ai été mariée trois fois c'est
elle qui l'envoie eu la patience jeudi
les femmes sont de plus tant d'ennemis
arrêts c'est vrai ce sont autant tu n'as
pas d'expérience ben j'ai souffert le
mans favre tu as tes larmes entre mes
blessures
ainsi un regard françoise ici je serai à
l'itie à dans le doubs regarde quelle
horreur d'anciens combattants elle a
beaucoup souffert quand même un peu et
ça se voit et en ce qui concerne ton
précédent divorce tu as dit le temps
passe mais je ne pardonne pas oui et
quelquefois je pardonne pas oui bah t'as
pas le cas l'été celui d'avant là le
printemps dernier les dix dernières sais
pas si c'est 10 de ton écoute on en fait
tout un plat mais enfin je me suis
mariée deux fois c'est le moindre dingue
et céline tu vas d'épouser ça c'est mon
petit jardin
ah c'est vrai que tu l'a rencontrée sur
le plateau du monde est à vous oui ça
s'est passé comment simplement
comment s'est rencontré sur un plateau à
tous les deux oui enfin on a bien fait
parce m'arriver tu vois on sait pas
comment ça ce sera terminé quand elle
avait ce qui se passe ce soir
dis moi tu es dit céline m'a réconcilié
avec les femmes alors c'est facile et
boussu bien parce qu'elle m'a apporté
beaucoup de choses que je n'avais jamais
su tu dis ça à chaque fois non mais non
cette fois c'est différent
rip shot fois je vais finir par passer
pour barclays ont débarqué en deux
femmes j'aimerais bien tu verbois télex
prévenus ont par exemple eu l'armoire
elle est incontournable aux étudiants
leur rencontre partait au crédit clady
treuil des mon dieu à une époque où il
ça a été vraiment mon maître à penser
est saint lô site a un peu changé d'avis
c'est bien changer d'avis heureusement
que depuis c'est ainsi interview
accordée dans lesquels on diamanka
blement des bêtises c'est bien pour sens
doping chalon avis serait très monotone
et moi j'ai horreur des gens qui ne
changent pas d'avis ça fait combien
d'années de psychanalyse 8 en 8 ans et
si aujourd'hui tu pratiques en fait tu
va pratiquer un moment là la
psychanalyse toi même c'est devenu
analyste ouamer en ont un petit peuple
intéressés pendant des années je m'y
intéresse toujours enfin déclaré un
livre intéressant j'en prends
connaissance mais disons tous assez
seiller si tu me voyais arriver moi un
jour en te demandant de m'analyser
quelle serait la première question que
tu me poserai la première question je ne
tends poserait pas avant
j'attendrai le temps tu ne demanderait
pas si je peux te payer par exemple mon
nom au nord une bonne confession set
virait alors là j'en raffole
j'y ai passé mon adolescence et moi
georges on va recommencer tu me suis un
au revoir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tantum ergo s'aggrave at elle tenté
pendant qu'aux malades au quotidien
depuis presque dix mois
tu as dit les petits anges j'ai mis
longtemps d'en débarrasser l'enfer le
paradis
aujourd'hui tu as l'air un peu moins
aussi que les ricanements écoutez moi je
suis un peu comme pascal à ce fait le
même pari je parie sur le fait que dieu
existe
tu remarqueras au passage que c'est bien
un auvergnat le pascal parce que parier
sur lui et canaux vergnet qui veulent
quoi tu l'appelles le hasard dieu tu
tombes un autre nom toit et les
bisontins crépel leurs armes étoiles
alors disons kamel alors ça tombe très
bien parce que j'ai une grande
admiration pour la religion bien senti
c'est vrai que la bible et on livre de
chevet c'est exact tu lis souvent tous
les soirs et quelquefois le matin et en
plus c'est pas un bouquin trice très
joyeux et assez paillard ça dépend des
chats qui est ce que finalement ça peut
être illusoire de croire que tu pouvait
échapper au p'tit jacques du collège
je suis toujours resté le p'tit jacques
du collège et les mêmes terreur
je déteste autant les adultes
je suis resté le garçon que j'étais au
pensionnat il faut pas le dire ça me
fera du tort
un dernier mot amen
[Musique]